what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time i'm here with
the beautiful intelligent pelina eva
luva marinovo well while she's trying to
get rich for us
just trying to get lunch money right
georgia lost
they lost least
alabama nick saban that's fine whatever
but it won like everything else
it doesn't matter uh don't forget that
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five block by has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on the crypto exchange you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan
or three my favorite product i'm an
investor i sit on the board and you
should go get an account go get a damn
account
at blockfi you can get an interest
bearing account that earns up to eight
point six percent
apy go to block fight.com pomp
go get the damn account i've been saying
this over and over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again
get money get paid go get a blackfy
account at blackpine.com pop and earn up
to 8.6
apy they make all this stuff possible so
you get to see her every day
go get an account what's up one more
announcement
as many of you know i also write
something called the profile which
studies the world's most interesting and
successful people
every week you can sign up at
readtheprofile.com but also
also i have a great interview coming out
tomorrow so make sure you subscribe to
my youtube channel
called paulina marinova i think that's
that's what it's called
and it's on youtube so go subscribe like
we'll link to
okay in the comments so tomorrow
big interview are you are you running
free ads right now is that an
ad it's just an announcement i'm the
co-host okay that's fine what's up
okay the senate the senate will vote on
a 500 billion
coronavir stimulus bill on wednesday
mitch mcconnell
said as a larger bipartisan deal remains
elusive despite continued talks between
top democrats and trump administration
do you want to tell them about what we
watched the other day that makes this
look like
yeah i mean this is all stupid like what
i'm not even paying attention to the 500
billion dollar bill this is all
political
how many bills have how many no the
democrats put up a bill they pass it
then it gets shot down then the senate
does it they get shot down whatever it's
fine
uh we watched the um there's a new
documentary called hank
on hank paulson uh it's on netflix yeah
it's on netflix uh who
uh was the secretary of the treasury
during the global financial crisis and
they sit him down
and they go through every single
decision they made uh it made me like
hank paulson a lot more uh and because
it showed the
the thought process behind his decision
making and the fact that he wasn't the
only one making that
well no none of that contributed to what
i like them more
but that's why i played it might like
them more uh it was
actually his belief that he was doing
things that he believed were actually
wrong in terms of uh he disagreed with
the bailouts but he felt like he was in
a position where he had to do them
um and so he kind of walks through how
did he get to the point where he was
doing things that he disagreed with
um which is fascinating but also
dissonance
but also too is when they're talking
about like
200 billion dollars or 300 billion
dollars uh it's hysterical now to see
that literally we're talking about
trillions of dollars and stimulus a
decade later so we'll see
this what's next one one okay so
is it yuan or one one okay tens of five
actually it might be
you won but whatever the chinese
currency tens of thousands
of chinese this week spent digital yuan
won at walmart gas stations and
convenience stores across the southern
tech hub of shenzhen
the experiment unprecedented in the
scope and size went off without a hitch
catapulted catapulting the world's
number two economy to the forefront of a
race
to develop virtual money
wow so we have a digital one yes what i
wrote about this morning oh did you
a year ago it's free today so that's
fine
a year ago or so i went on cnbc
and this is what i said the u.s has to
digitize the dollar it has to
if we don't we will fall behind and has
to do it immediately
i even went some people may remember
this i went and i spent two days in
washington dc talking to a bunch of
politicians
yeah he left me behind yeah put on like
my little suit and tie that i got from
kohl's
and i took the train down to washington
dc and i met with a bunch of these
people
and they didn't care nobody cared nobody
wanted to listen that's fine well guess
where we find ourselves a year later
china is now testing the currency a
digital currency
and they're getting great results in
terms of adoption and usage
and the u.s today was the first time
that the
fed chairman powell gave a
talk at the imf it was interviewed with
imf and he started talking about digital
currency
like oh we're gonna look at the central
bank digital currency thing but they're
talking about like maybe we'll build one
in the next couple of years
this is not a next couple of years thing
this is a right now
thing and if they don't act the u.s is
going to fall
really far behind china because it all
comes down to accessibility
if i'm sitting somewhere in the world
and i can use an internet connection i
want a global currency
can i get the want or can i get the
dollar and china is increasingly
a cashless society so i think for them
adoption of this is much
easier ultimately it's not going to
matter because everyone's going to
choose bitcoin
because what ends up happening is all
the fiat currencies will be digitized at
some point in the future
and so the technology layer everything
will be digitized the competition's
gonna have it happen at the monetary
policy
layer and china's monetary policy and
the u.s yes there are differences
but they're both fiat currencies they
both have unlimited supply
they're both uh decisions are made by
humans they
also have very little transparency they
have tons of cyber security concerns
when they digitize them
and and and one of the most important
parts of the whole thing
is that when you go and you do this
you drastically increase government
surveillance because now it's a cashless
society they can see all your
transactions
do you think that in the future cash is
actually just going to be like kind of
like a taboo or like
the drug dealers are going to use it or
i mean i mean
they do right now but i'm just saying
like the physical us dollars the choice
currency of
uh money uh launderers terrorists and
criminals around the world but do you
think that in the future it'll be like
taboo to have cash
i think at some point in my lifetime
they'll actually take physical cash out
of circulation
whoa yeah it is kind of crazy to think
about that we walk around with these
like paper
things and just exchange paper it's kind
of weird yeah um
so ultimately people are going to choose
bitcoin bitcoin is the superior monetary
policy in terms of protecting your
wealth
and uh the jig is up central banks are
now an innovator's dilemma they will not
disrupt themselves because that'll mean
a lot to relinquish power but
it's going to happen uh and just so
we're clear
like that scares the hell out of me
right like that literally scares the
hell out of me
well think of the us's position in the
world
china's position in the world all of
these superpowers
if all of a sudden they don't have
control over our currency like
many people would argue that the
greatest weapon the u.s has in
any war is monetary policy and like the
ability to
sanction like right how's it going in
venezuela
north korea iran like in all these
places
we just sanctioned them and cut them off
from the global financial system but if
we no longer have the power to do that
what what happens in that world um also
fun
fact yeah what's your fun fact no your
fun fact um
he he said about the war the u.s has
only been
at peace and not at war or in some kind
of court
i think the united states since
inception in 1776
which is 244 years
uh we've spent 225 of them at war
with somebody so literally less than 20
years
uh does it count the civil war like
internal war uh
but i do think that uh it's pretty crazy
less than 20 years in the history of the
united states have we spent a full year
without
uh engaged in a violent conflict
so remember if you're 18 years old in
the united states today you've never
lived a day in your life without the
united states engaged
in one of the two wars in the middle
east all right
okay china speaking of china
china's economy recovered further from
the quran virus in the third quarter
according to data released by the
national bureau of statistics
the world's second largest economy
reported third quarter gdp
growth on the low end of expectations up
4.9 percent from a year ago
that brings growth for the first three
quarters of the year to 0.7
from a year ago it's still lower
than it was uh in q1
of two years oh wait what do you have
last year no
q1 of this year it's still lower where's
q1 of this year
well that's why the chart looks like
that um
and also from q4 last year as well so
yes they are recovering it's great uh
the recovery has slowed
right so it literally looks like it was
a v off the bottom and now it's kind of
going at a 40
this is what a v-shaped recovery is
supposed to be uh
well here's the problem is the numbers
that they're looking at here
is just gdp so the gdp is recovering
stock prices are recovering in many
markets around the world but
the other underlying economic data is
not recovering
and so there's a kind of you can spend
the data to tell whatever story you want
retail sales are still in contraction
all that and stuff that matters yeah so
you can tell the story whatever you want
but the chinese
uh recovery is still underway
but it is still lower than pre-pandemic
levels by a little bit
um and we'll see what happens but
remember in wuhan china we're talking
about this weekend
in wuhan china uh back in august
there's a massive massive
uh concert in a pool
if you google wuhan china concert
you'll see articles from august there's
i don't know
thousands of people that are literally
in these pools
uh kind of like a wet and wild type like
uh thing
and it's a concert and they're all in
there there's no mass there's no social
distancing there's no anything i don't
really trust
what china is telling us of course about
the virus but
well the articles are written by like
u.s publications so i'm assuming they
did some facts no no who knows
yeah but what's crazy is they claim that
that happened
three months after the last coronavirus
case
in their economy or in their society i
have no clue
but it's just interesting to see their
response difference in the place where
this
reportedly allegedly uh originated from
you know okay what's up what's next you
know robert t
brockman he's a texas tech mogul a
federal grand jury returned an
indictment alleging that brockman the
ceo
of software company reynolds and
reynolds engaged in tax invasion wire
fraud
money laundering and other crimes as
part of a nearly 20-year scheme to
conceal around two billion dollars in
income
from the irs and defraud investors in
his software's form debt
securities federal authority said this
is the largest ever
tax charge in the history of the united
states
two billion dollar tax evasion case
i mean this is wild so again this is a
39 count indictment filed earlier this
month in the northern district of
california it was unsealed this week it
reads like a screenplay
so here's allegations allegations right
i'm always super careful with this stuff
there's an allegation who knows what's
actually true the allegations against
him include operating a complex web of
foreign companies and bank accounts
using unreported taxable income to buy a
luxury yacht called turmoil
it's creating an encrypted email system
to communicate with employees using code
names such as bonefish and snapper
he asked a money manager allegedly to
attend a money laundering conference
using an assumed identity and persuading
that same money manager to destroy
documents and electronic media using
shredders and hammers
dollar amounts aside i have not seen
this pattern of greed or concealed and
cover up
in my 25 plus years as a special agent
said an irs criminal investigation unit
uh chief look i don't know what happened
what i do know is that there's all kinds
of uh intricacies
in these uh tax situations when you're
talking about that much money
uh it's a just different world and so
we'll see what happens
will come out that is the beauty wait
that is the beauty there's a wrinkle
brockman is an investor in vista equity
partners
yeah it doesn't surprise me oh really i
mean they're both in texas robert
smith is the one who also recently got
hit with a tax
uh situation situation yeah the whole
thing is like look
uh this is what makes the united states
so great is
people who are charged with something
will go to court and the court will
decide
what happened and what didn't i i
reserve all uh
what they call it um assumption yeah
like i reserve all of my
uh judgments until uh we see what the
court says so okay
that's it but hey it happened what's
next all right
so there's a family in upstate new york
who was doing renovations
to their home and they found dozens of
whiskey bottles dating back to the 1920s
hidden
in their walls and floorboards sick it
was
the home was once owned by a prohibition
era bootlegger
look at these photos oh wow
so they found it in the walls they found
it in the
like it's literally like the entire
thing is covered they're rich
they're rich people who probably willing
to pay all kinds of money that's true
that's true so so he said it blows my
mind that this was buried in our walls
for almost a hundred years without
anyone knowing the couple wrote
um and there's a photo of a whiskey
bottle dated from 1923 that's older than
my great-grandmother
she was born in 1929 um it was a pretty
legit
hiding place we've counted 42 bottles so
far we're leaving most of them in their
original bundles for now what does that
mean so they're not gonna
well that's what they're like that's
protecting them
hey maybe maybe they'll drink some we'll
see all right what's next
all right neil degrasse tyson
saying that there is an asteroid that
could hit the united states on november
2nd which is the day before the election
nasa has confirmed that it's on a
trajectory to possibly hit the u.s on
november 2nd
it's 6.5 feet in diameter diameter and
there's only a 1
chance it'll hit somewhere in the
country but still it's 20 20. there was
a two percent chance i remember when
donald trump
got elected for him to get elected he
still got elected
what are the chances of coronavirus
happening one percent chance it will hit
somewhere in the country but still
it's 20. if an asteroid hits the u.s
in 2020 also this tmz article can catch
me later
it says the space agency is saying there
are three possible points of impact
but they weren't specific great
oh god oh no i ain't screwing out with
none of this
the asteroid is as big as a refrigerator
but it's also traveling at
25 000 miles per hour
so like a refrigerator
tell the aliens next tell me hit me with
your next [ __ ] it would be turned into
like powder
immediately i've turned that into powder
have you seen my muscles
are you kidding me okay all right hit me
with your joke so i don't have a joke
for today but i do have a story
that is funny that i will tell that you
are not allowed to tell ready guys
so yesterday we went on a ride on an
uber to meet our friends in brooklyn
and our uber driver happened to be
someone that is super religious who
decided that in the period of time
between
for our ride he would not pitch us on
his religion but basically try to
convert us to his religion
and there was a lot of like um
well sometimes when people do bad things
like
god will step in and do something even
worse so you can prove your love
to god it was i get really uncomfortable
in religious talks this was
extremely uncomfortable so finally we
listened we listened anthony hits me
and i know something wild's coming so
the next thing that came out of his
mouth was
all right well um can i put you on my
religion
and i'm like this this can only go one
way and all i hear is
have you heard of satoshi
so yeah i got my guy i told him hey man
because he said that he uh
he puts his money in the bank and takes
it out immediately he doesn't want to
leave the money but i was like oh let me
tell you about my religion
there's this guy satoshi and i just went
through the whole thing
and he he was like i don't know i don't
play around with that stuff and i was
like i'm just telling you man
you're already a believer and you don't
even know it
all right guys truly it was awesome it
was funny
everyone got a good laugh we'll see you
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products they can give you a us
dollar loan
you can earn up to 8.6 interest on an
interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends